bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
analyser le trailer de Doctor Strange 2
Multiverse of madness pour ceux qui ne
savent pas je suis un enfant du docteur
et son second film on l'attend depuis un
moment on en a déjà beaucoup parlé sur
la chaîne mais franchement quel bonheur
d'avoir enfin des premiers visuels avant
de commencer je vous invite à vous
abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas
encore déjà fait il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire là avec les arrêts sont
sortis que ce soit Spiderman au héros
mais en particulier ici-bas Docteur
Strange 2 donc voilà on va pas mal en
parler dans les mois à venir bref tout
d'abord il faut mettre un peu de
contexte et quelques warning nous sommes
face à un trailer donc prenons un peu de
recul dans l'avant déjà parlé dans la
vidéo dédiée à Spider-Man noir homme que
je vous invite à voir mais aujourd'hui
les trailer de Marvel nous manipule
beaucoup donc il y a de grandes chances
que Marvel tente de nous faire croire
certaines choses qui n'arriveront pas
dans le film donc voilà rester vigilant
ensuite j'aimerais également dire que
premier trailer donc avant tout une mise
en bouche je peux vous assurer que l'on
sait rien du film avec cette bande
annonce surtout quand on prend
conscience de tout les rumeurs qui
entoure ce dernier d'ailleurs petites
choses que j'aime bien faire quand je
dois analyser un trailer se revoir ce
des anciens films car vous serez
peut-être surpris mais ils sont toujours
construit de la même manière j'ai revu
le tout premier trailer de Doctor
Strange et figurez-vous qu'on ne voit
rien de spécial dedans il n'y avait même
pas où on dit il n'y avait pas de
Dormammu et il tente et même de nous
faire croire que ces lieux était le
véritable méchant donc voilà néanmoins
voyons ce que nous pouvons en tirer il y
a des choses très intéressantes à
relever premièrement il faut se rappeler
que Doctor Strange 2 Multiverse of
madness s'inscrit dans une sorte de
trilogie c'est Kevin qui lui-même le
papa du MCU qui nous avait t'affirmer
que Huong la vision Spider-Man noir et
Docteur Strange 2 était très fortement
relié et forme en tout en gros Docteur
Strange 2 et en la conclusion entre
guillemets de cette trilogie ce film vas
répondre à plusieurs éléments introduit
dans Wonder vision et et Spider-Man 3
bien évidemment nous pensons à Honda qui
aura un rôle majeur dans le film et il
semblerait comme attendu que le
sortilège de Strange dans nos un homme
soit une conséquence de l'existence du
second aux puces du docteur puisque le
trailer démarre sur la conversation
entre Strange et longue concernant ce
fameux sort dit trop dangereux et qui
peut altérer l'espace-temps forcément ce
qui va découler de ça c'est le retour de
notre femme Mordo nous l'entendons même
dire que ce très je ne restera pas
impuni face à ses actes Bordeaux pour
rappel dans Doctor Strange a
complètement vriller quand il a appris
que l'ancien tirer ses pouvoirs de la
dimension noir dans le but d'atteindre
une certaine immortalité puis il n'a pas
supporté non plus que Strange joue avec
la pierre du temps pour défaire Dormammu
et ramener la ville à son état d'antan
Bordeaux je rigole pas avec les lois de
l'univers et cela va le conduire vers
une certaine noirceur une noire sœur qui
avait déjà été utilisé dans la scène
post-générique du premier Docteur
Strange où ce dernier avait supprimé les
pouvoirs de Penboc'h non jugeant qu'il
existe trop de sorcier voulant dire par
là trop de gens qui peuvent briser les
lois de l'univers et donc [ __ ] en
l'air la réalité si j'insiste sur le
caractère de Bordeaux c'est parce que
cela définit clairement son personnage
ce dernier et même en possession du
bâton du tribunal vivant pour nous faire
comprendre que ce dernier se prend pour
un juge une entité supérieure capable de
choisir si oui ou non quelqu'un doit
vivre car il menacerait l'univers et
tout ça là on le retrouve dans le
trailer puisque Mordo s'oppose à strange
lui affirmant clairement qu'il est la
plus grande menace de l'univers il se
sert des possibles conséquences du sort
de Strange dans nos héros pour le
confronter sur le sujet sauf que l'âme
de Bordeaux et rigide et câble comme
l'affirme est l'ancien il faut par
moment savoir en train de les règles
pour l'intérêt général et ceci Strange
en as conscience ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas de Morteau désormais avec ce
second aux puces nous avons de très
grandes chances d'avoir à l'écran à
Bordeaux qui se rapprocherait de ce
qu'il était dans les comics avec le
titre de baron à Bordeaux qui deviendrai
donc le plus grand rival de Doctor
Strange un sorcier qui serait devenu
sinistre et qui n'hésiterai pas à
utiliser la magie noire pour arriver à
ses fins et le truc c'est que la
présence d'un Evil Docteur Strange ne va
pas du tout et des à convaincre Bordeaux
effectivement il y a de très grandes
chances voir c'est même obligé à part si
c'est une illusion ou possible de me
quelqu'un d'autre mais qu'il s'agisse du
Docteur Strange présent dans what if
sauf que ce Docteur Strange a
complètement Annie Lessard réalité dans
what if Mordo qui est déjà très rigide
et énervé contre notre Docteur Strange
qui les règles par moment si il apprend
qu'un Strange d'une autre réalité a
complètement annihiler la sienne bah ça
ne va pas le faire du tout et justement
dans les comics Bordeaux et quelqu'un
qui n'hésite pas à faire les coups les
plus bas et surtout à pactiser avec des
êtres plus grand que lui comme Dormammu
par exemple et c'est là que cela devient
intéressant il est clair que Mordo ne
sera pas l'antagoniste principal du film
déjà car premièrement Docteur Strange la
Fronde que des gros entité cosmique et
Multiverse elle nous avons eu Dormammu
dans le premier film et même Thanos dans
Infinity war donc pour son s aux puces
où il est encore plus fort il faudra un
antagoniste tout aussi grand et puissant
Bordeaux n'est pas suffisant pour passer
après un Dorman 2 + Strange n'agit pas
pour lui mais pour le monde il sait
pourquoi il fait les arts mystiques
l'ancien elle-même lui avait dit qu'il
aurait pu rentrer chez lui ai juste
soigner ses mains mais non Strange a
fait le choix de servir une cause qui le
dépasse et nous comment retrouver cette
thématique lors de son combat contre
Dormammu Strange à affronter l'entité
pour protéger le monde et nous
retrouvons cette même thématique quand
le Evil Doctor Strange dans what if
s'est rendu compte de ses actes liés à
la tendance du Multiverse il nous faut
donc un ennemi Multiverse elle est
capable de me menacer un monde entier et
que Strange devra affronter un an et
demi qui a fortes chances pour être
rappelé par Morteau pour justement
nettoyer la réalité des sorciers qu'ils
en prennent les règles et ne respecte
pas les lois naturelles de l'univers au
même carrément juste annuler la réalité
car mordoré jugé que c'était trop tard à
cause de Strange et comme ça tu es très
alité ne me lasserai pas les autres du
multivers par exemple bon ce sont des
spéculations juste comme ça mais je suis
désolé il va falloir que nous parlions
de chaume Agora on a déjà beaucoup
parler c'est antagoniste mais en même
temps il est tellement parfait pour
Docteur Strange 2 pour rappel chomag
Horace est une entité faisant partie de
ce qu'on appelle les l'ancien n'est à
l'aube de l'univers il fait parti de
ceux qui ont créé la magie du chaos ce
dernier est attendu pour apparaître dans
Doctor Strange 2 et pour cause chaume
Agora est un des plus grand ennemi de
Doctor Strange il permet de relier
également Rwanda au récit étant lié à la
magie du chaos et surtout si nous
faisons bel et bien face au Evil Docteur
Strange de what if et bien ce dernier
est déjà côtoyer dans la série et a même
absorbé quelques tentacules lui
appartenant d'ailleurs à l'origine
chômage voyage à travers les réalités
pour les ânes il est où les conquérir
donc voilà c'est une menace parfaite
pour Docteur Strange 2 et ça colle
parfaitement au thématique du film et à
celle du multivers se pourrait que ce
soit enfermé dans une dimension et que
quelqu'un allait libérer pour justement
mettre le bazar cependant non il ne
s'agit pas de chômage dans le trailer ce
dernier est beaucoup plus massif est
primordial que ça il s'agit à très
fortes chances de Gargan tôt ce qui
meilleur a été utilisé avec le
merchandising des jouets du film et là
il a quelque chose d'intéressant à
souligner c'est le gars quand on est un
monstre liés normalement à Atlantis et
par conséquent à l'histoire du Wakanda
étant donné que Black Panther 2 sur
plusieurs mois après Docteur Strange 2
et qu'il y a de fortes chances que Namor
fasse son apparition dans le film avec
les femmes secousses que nous avions eu
dans endgame et bien Docteur Strange
Multiverse of madness pourrait t'être la
raison de l'arrivée du monstre qui
apparaîtrait dans Black Panther 2
pourquoi pas également dans le trailer
nous avons eu la surprise d'avoir des
premiers visuels concernant America
Chavez ce qui est intéressant avec cette
dernière c'est qu'elle ne viens pas de
notre réalité à la base mais surtout son
pouvoir signature à quelle peut créer
des portails en forme d'étoile
permettant de voyager à travers les
réalités et donc le multivers j'espère
personnellement qu'elle aura un impact
important dans le film et qu'elle ne
servira pas seulement à voyager à
travers les dimensions à tous les coups
c'est elle qui va permettre d'amener il
est caméo attendu pour le film comme
évite Docteur Strange des X-Men comme
possiblement magnéto où Charles Xavier
ou encore réderie de chazoux Captain
carter ils sont normalement tous prévu
pour apparaître dans le film d'ailleurs
dans ce cas mais au moins je suis sûr
qu'il a ramènerai magnéto puisque c'est
l'historique parfait pour coller à venda
puisque dans les comics c'est
normalement son père à l'origine nous
avons également la présence de Rindra et
il fallait bien le voir ce dernier
ressemble à un minotaure avec la peau
verte et dans les comics il est l'un des
plus grands alliés de Strange jusqu'à
même devenir son apprenti ils vont
certainement se rencontrer par le biais
du multivers et vu sa présence à
camartage cela semble correspondre au
fait qu'il est un allié et possiblement
un futur élève comme dans les comics et
qui dit également un nouveau film dédié
à un personnage dit forcément évolution
et donc par conséquent pour Strange de
nouveau pouvoir à la manière de Speedy
qui a évolué ça sent Spider c'est c'est
c'est costume ou encore d'autres héros
comme Thor avec ce temps breaker et bien
Strange va me maîtriser de la nouvelle
magie et pas n'importe laquelle puisque
nous le voyons utiliser la magie du
chaos mais qu'il est également capable
de balancer des créatures du multivers
camartage n'a plus aucun secret pour lui
il a lu tous les livres ce qui signifie
que se savoir ils auraient par des
billets externe à la bibliothèque du
sanctuaire puisqu'il est capable
d'appréhender la magie du chaos nous
pouvons penser que vendent à y est pour
quelque chose mais il y a de fortes
chances que ce soit grâce au dark old
introduit dans des vision nous savons
que c'est où Honda qui le détient et vu
que Strange va la voir chez elle pour
lui demander de l'aide il est possible
qu'il y a eu accès aux livres d'amener
d'ailleurs le Dark Maul de son de
contenir un savoir important sur le
multivers un élément qui pourrait aider
Strange dans sa quête et concernant le
lancement de créatures magiques il se
peut que Doctor Strange l'état prix
grâce au Evil Docteur Strange qui avait
explorer de Fontan combles la
bibliothèque de Cagliostro mais bon cela
reste à voir d'ailleurs un autre petit
mot sur le Evil Docteur Strange mets le
trailer semble faire passer pour un
antagoniste personnellement je pense
qu'il s'agit d'un piège déjà nous savons
qu'au fond il n'est pas mauvais de par
les événements de what if enfin si c'est
bien celui de what if mais pour moi
c'est sûr mais surtout on sait que Sam
Raimi te commande et il y a quelque
chose d'intéressant par rapport à cela
n'a rien qu'en reprenant les premiers
Spider-Man qu'il avait été effectuée
nous retrouvons toujours ce dédoublement
de personnage avec le bon côté et sa
part sombre comme le Bouffon Vert et
Norman Osborn ou Toby Maguire est le
célèbre de Lima meilleur enfin il faut
que nous parlions de Wang effectivement
nous avons appris que ce dernier était
devenu de sorcier suprême dans
Spider-Man noir homme parce que Doctor
Strange était absent pendant 5 ans à
cause du snap de Thanos le truc c'est
que nous savons que Strange est destiné
à avoir ce titre un jour ou l'autre se
lance elle-même qui disait qu'il était
destiné à devenir le meilleur des
sorciers suprême avec le second aux
puces du docteur il y a de très fortes
chances que ce dernier épouse enfin ce
rôle qui lui est dédié le personnage
dois avancer et évoluer on a pas eu
l'occasion de voir un véritable
avancement sur le personnage depuis son
premier film en 2016 malheureusement si
on détient ce titre et que Strange dois
lui prendre il est possible qu'un acte
malheureux se passe dans le film
concernant où on dit peut-être que ce ne
sera pas le cas mais il n'y a pas de
raison que vous on arrête d'être sorcier
suprême et Strange dois pourtant le
devenir donc cela reste à voir
d'ailleurs Cyrille tra appareil il y a
de grandes chances qu'il soit un nouveau
compagnon pour Strange donc il pourrait
techniquement prendre la place d'un
colis tu que symbolise longue mais voilà
ce n'est pas ce que je souhaite surtout
que maintenant en plus ou moins longues
est lié à chaque fille et à oui par
rapport à Christine Palmer le plan d'eau
montrant son mariage était très
intéressant Pirelli à tous cette
thématique d'amour qui entoure
l'histoire de Strange même si le docteur
et Christine sont très liés ces
dernières semble avoir tourné la page
concernant Steven est normal dur de
cohabiter avec un sorcier de Carthage
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que si
Christine est marié et s'éloigne petit à
petit du tableau cela ouvre la porte à
strange pour s'ouvrir vers de nouvelles
personnes et pourquoi pas tomber
amoureux de quelqu'un d'autre et là
inutile de vous faire un dessin je pense
bien évidemment à Cléa le grand amour de
Docteur Strange dans les comics alors je
le précise je ne pense pas que cela
arriverait dans ce film mais c'est déjà
un premier pas vers cette possible
future relation peut-être pourquoi pas
dans un Docteur Strange 3
écouter je pense avoir dit pas mal de
choses concernant le trailer cela ne
reflète évidemment que ma pensée est mon
avis à vous de me dire si j'ai oublié
quelque chose et puis bah s'il y a un
élément particulier qui vous ait ou si
tout simplement Bah le film vous
intéresse grandement j'espère en tout
cas que ma vidéo vous aura plu je vous
invite à aller voir une de mes
précédentes vidéo où justement nous
parlions aux énormément de chaume à
gauras de Doctor Strange 2 de one de la
vision et cetera et je trouve
personnellement que cette vidéo est
toujours d'actualité donc voilà cela
peut vous intéresser je vous invite
aller la voir puis écoutez n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la chaîne à laisser un
petit pouce bleu Docteur Strange 2 et un
film qui me I depuis très longtemps on
en avait déjà beaucoup parlé à l'époque
même sans aucune information et là le
fait qu'on se rapproche du film qu'on
est enfin des premiers visuels bah c'est
clairement il paraît pas en quoi je suis
trop content c'est un plaisir d'avoir pu
analyser cette bande-annonce avec vous
et d'avoir enfin pu parler un petit peu
concrètement de Doctor Strange 2 je vous
souhaite à tous
joyeux Noël des bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année et puis bah écoute et que le
line rare soit avec vous c'était argorok
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]